the state has passed its general project
plan which leads to eminent domain they
are contesting that in court will wait
for the litigation between those two
property owned commercial property
owners and the state to resolve itself I
should underscore Columbia very early on
said under no conditions would it seek
eminent domain with respect to any
residential properties so we're really
talking about two commercial property
owners and we'll wait and see how the
still pending the Robert maybe the one
thing we should underscore there though
is when we look at this development area
which is 17 acres it has been one of the
single largest assemblages of property
in New York City and what I mean by that
specifically is every parcel essentially
every parcel was owned by a different
property owner and one at a time from
2002 minus the two properties that we
have it actually it's six properties to
owners that we haven't acquired yet
under Roberts leadership and through a
guy named Phil Silverman who is our vice
president for real estate we've been
able to acquire ever every property and
at the end of that acquisition being a
place with the owner of that property
where they're actually feeling very very
good very good about their future as a
business if they wanted to stay in
business we've relocated several
businesses and really created the
opportunity for other folks to get out
of a business quite frankly that they
had been trying to get out of and didn't
have a way to do that so I think we've
delivered a very very positive result at
the end of the day and as Robert said
will you know we'll continue to work
through the process on on the two
remaining but not to lose sight of what
really has already taken place it was
actually very interesting because after
all this is New York City and there were
over the last number of years some tough
moments but our experience on the inside
with the community is at
variants with what the Press reported so
that I remember my mother-in-law sending
me an article describing a meeting we
had attended in West Harlem and it was
in one of the London newspapers actually
and it was accompanied by an email note
about how sorry they were feeling for me
and how terrible things were as I it
didn't happen I mean I just so that Joe
and I were actually chatting before the
meeting started Columbia University not
only is a university where people work
in this community but one out of every
three staff people live in this
community and when I say this community
I don't mean Manhattan I mean community
board 910 Street 250 fifth Street and as
a result the way in which we behave has
to be consistent with the highest
standards we're staying here we're not
like private developers those private
developers who can build the building
and then move on to another part of the
city or another part of the country
we're going to live with the people
we're affecting and when Joe talks about
making people happy it's not simply
because we overpaid I don't think money
is really what it's about we have worked
sometimes it's been harder than other
times I'm sure we've made mistakes but
we've worked so that when we're done the
community feels that having Columbia
here is to everyone's advantage and it's
it's really it allows us to come to work
and feel good about it please